ouais maman c'est à quelle heure qu'il
faut arriver à maison Jeanne d'Arc
tombe bien j'étais pile en train de
regarder le programme et bah 18h30
claire Vicken a en ce moment un emploi
du temps très chargé cette jeune fille
de 16 ans élève de seconde et dernière
d'une fratrie de 4 enfants s'apprête à
vivre la plus folle semaine de sa jeune
existence elle en rêve depuis une
dizaine d'années moi je pense que c'est
quand à 5 ans et demi j'ai défilé
costumé dans le cortège
d'action grâce derrière Jeanne d'Arc et
je pense que c'est à partir de ce moment
là où j'ai commencé à avoir un vrai réel
intérêt pour pour Jeanne d'Arc ça
désignation en tant qu'incarnation de
jeunes 2023 a été une joie pour toute la
famille une fierté et une évidence car
Jeanne d'Arc est dans cette maison un
symbole majeur alors nous c'est vrai
qu'en plus on lui a particulièrement
parlé de Jeanne et on lui racontait les
histoires de jeunes je pense qu'elle
avait quelques mois
donc elle a toujours baigné dedans donc
au niveau de la transmission oui je
crois que la clairvie que ce soit de mon
papa qui a 83 ans jusqu'à jusqu'au tout
petit et elle a toujours baigné dans
Jeanne ici Jeanne d'Arc est un guide
spirituel mais son interprète 2023 ne
veut surtout pas apparaître comme une
égérie catholique elle se donne une
mission très actuelle et nécessaire
c'est vrai que on n'est pas dans une
société qui nous incite trop les jeunes
à s'engager et que et que c'est vrai que
ben moi ça fait écho de m'intéresser
justement à
au monde en fait et que justement enfin
faut pas avoir peur de montrer ses
valeurs ces convictions et qu'il faut
des jeunes comme ça on en a plus que
besoin aujourd'hui
la jeune Jeanne 2023 s'inscrit dans une
longue tradition locale cette année il
s'agit de la
594ème édition des fêtes Johanniques